the people around the club when they
make decisions and have to make what
these decisions they think are right and
that's their decision so I'd you know I
by by that I don't hold grudges I don't
spend my life worrying about you know
what could have been and people you know
that's life we all move on and you know
I've left behind some fantastic players
I think the only disappointment I think
it was a team that could have gone on in
all honesty and won the Premier League
eventually in the next year or two and I
think they were think they can I just
wish I'd been able to see that for and
be part of that because I think the
talent near and the players they've got
some fun they've got some fantastic
players here as for your conversations
with Daniel Levy what was said and how
amicable were they I mean no fine don't
you just said they were you know it was
nothing to do with contracts on me
asking for for anything at all I the
year left and obviously no that was fine
it was just a case of I think the club
decided they wanted to to have a change
so let's test their OS their option they
are new club they can do whatever they
want